I hope you're prepared for titanfall 2
because it looks like you might be able
to hop back into a Titan sooner than
expected according to UK retailer game
respawns titanfall 2 will be released in
2016 the titanfall 2 page at the store's
website shows at TBC 2016 release window
for the shooter sequel and
videogamer.com took notice this date
could be a placeholder but it seems to
line up with a previous report from a
toy company creating action figures for
the sequel EA officially announced
titanfall 2 last week with a brief
teaser trailer officially titanfall 2 is
scheduled to come out during the second
half a publisher ea's fiscal year this
means that it could come out anytime
between October 2016 and March 2017 this
is also the same release window is Mass
Effect Andromeda and the next mainline
battlefield game the original titanfall
came to xbox one pc and xbox 360 the
sequel however is rumored to launch on
ps4 as well rumors also report that the
game will have a proper single-player
mode something the original lacked if
you want to know more about titanfall 2
and the things you may have missed in
the trailer check out our teaser
breakdown on gamespot com
you